nosotros lo que esperamos desde que el
tribunal superior en vez más no
solamente analice la única causal que
estableció la jueza de la instancia que
se refería a una situación de integridad
física y más que todo psicológica de
julian assange como una situación de
inminencia suicidio sino que también de
que afectan derechos fundamentales y
derechos humanos de señor assange esto
en primera instancia fue ampliamente
debatido dilucidado y demostrado que
afectaba la libertad de expresión hacia
su información y derecho de opinión sin
embargo estas consideraciones no fueron
tomados en cuenta por la jueza y
esperamos que en este apoyo hacia 'la
tomados en cuenta y se haya elaborado y
haya valorado básicamente todo en un
contexto general